there's only two countries i believe in  the entire world where it's even legal  to advertise  uh prescription pharmaceuticals on tv  and in magazines and so on the usa and  new zealand so all these ads you see  like if you're all these ads every time  i'm looking at the screen these  pharmaceutical ads you know ask your  doctor about that's not even illegal  that's not even legal in most of the  world it's completely illegal across  europe it's illegal across asia it's  illegal in africa um and here it's cons  it's something like 60 to 70 of the tv  advertising revenue  and so that's a massive factor so  there's a huge incentive  for  drugs to be pushed whether this is even  even on children which is really  concerning right whether that's all of  these the amount of kids that are  drugged up here is is it's crazy